a sci-fi alien invasion action movie
version of Groundhog Day how would I not
be excited to see this movie
standing on the edge of tomorrow today
who doesn't think of that Saved by the
Bell the college years song when they
hear the title of his movie denial is
only the first stage you know you think
of it accept it so edgy tomorrow stars
Tom Cruise and Emily Blunt aliens have
invaded earth and they're taking over
Europe and then they're gonna take over
the world because aliens ultimately take
the PlayBook right from Hitler Tom
Cruise is this pencil-pushing military
officer he's public speaker he doesn't
do boar he's not really a soldier and he
kind of gets forced into the situation
where they're gonna storm the beats
pretty much the storming of Normandy
Beach but with aliens when they get
wiped out Tom Cruise boom wakes up and
then he starts today over again and this
is the premise of the movie every time
Tom Cruise dies he starts the day over
again in terms of sci-fi movies it
sounds pretty basically like oh okay so
he just relives the same day over and
over again I've seen that a few times
it's all about execution this movie felt
refreshing you're watching it you're
like this is cool it's intriguing it's
relatable like I don't want this movie
then Tom Cruise really brings it in his
movie I saw the trailer and I was like
probably not gonna be good it's really
cool seeing Tom Cruise refine the
situation on the beach at the point
where he's just going around just
wasting these guys you're boom we need
to get out of here boom like right now
BAM but in order to do that it's also
interesting seeing him just get wiped so
many times like reset button kind of
[ __ ] reminded me of hotline Miami
seriously if you guys have ever played
that you know how it is you go right the
rooms okay restart good restart boom
boom it cast
reminded me of that I was like this is
hotline Miami with aliens on a beach in
real military Mex and Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise and Emily Blunt are great in the
movie - funny thing is you start
thinking about it you're like maybe
that's the most unbelievable thing about
the movies the fact that every time he's
talking with Emily Blunt she's only
known him for a few hours and her mind's
eye they can't get too attached cuz
she's like I just met you but Tom Cruise
doesn't feel that way because he's met
her many times you don't feel that way
because Tom Cruise doesn't feel that way
for some odd reason you kind of fall
into it cuz you're like yeah I suppose
if someone like Tom Cruise so completely
knows someone even though they don't
really know then maybe they feel like
they know them too vicariously because
of their confidence in the fact that
they know them Adam a
I'm trying to force it but that's how I
saw it point is they're awesome together
and they have great chemistry another
thing is the fact that it's Tom Cruise
impresses me there's a point in time
where I was like Tom Cruise is
officially lost let's put him in the
Expendables for you watch this movie
you're like no but you can hold a movie
like this you don't have to put him
ironically in action movies you know and
make it kind of a joke like Arnold
Schwarzenegger you know how it is worse
like oh he's in an action movie it's
kind of a gimmick because he's not
really an action star anymore I'm crew
still has some miles on him that's cool
and no any movie that can pretty much
show me the same day over and over and
over again and make it feel new that's
never a bad thing it's actually really
hard to do that the only thing about the
movie is the last chunk of the movie was
the least interesting part of the movie
you would think you'd be amped up
because like oh it's like here's the
[ __ ] put it more concentrates on them
trying to do the end game rather than
the whole you know like death and reset
thing and the whole death and reset
thing at this point is the thing you've
grown attached to in the movie now
they're like alright let's just you know
do the thing so it does make you oh I
missed the hotline Miami feeling alright
Oh we'll still go along with the ride
though in the end edge of tomorrow is
proof that the summer of 2014 so far is
pretty awesome edge of tomorrow was well
acted Tom Cruise and Emily Blunt have
really good chemistry together the
supporting cast was really good in the
movie the premise is interesting it's
well executed movie keeps you on your
toes it keeps you engaged it's a solid
sci-fi movies one of those sci-fi movies
that even if people don't like sci-fi
they'd probably find this movie
interesting edge of tomorrow gives me
hope for the 2014 movies as a whole
because edge of tomorrow is awesome
tacular
you officially have a couple of great
movies to watch in the movie theaters if
you don't go now when are you gonna go
so edge of tomorrow have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more